senator bernie sanders says he's feeling
good after an emergency heart procedure
but his race for the Democratic
presidential nomination is on hold the
78 year old thanked the medical team
that treated him for a blocked artery
Sanders also used the episode to
highlight his campaign promise of
Medicare for all
ed O'Keefe is covering campaign 2020 and
how could this affect Sanders efforts
hey Tony you know a little too soon to
say but this health scare comes at a
critical moment for Sanders he raised
more than 25 million dollars in the most
recent fundraising quarter a big sum but
he's sliding in most polls into third
place
now his supporters and rivals wait to
see how long he'll be off the campaign
trail give me a chair up here from
Melissa's Anyang
it's a little long day yeah a day after
complaining of chest pains at a
fundraiser in Las Vegas senator Bernie
Sanders tweeted I'm feeling good he was
hospitalized Tuesday night for a common
heart procedure his campaign says he was
found to have a blockage in one artery
and two stents were successfully
inserted to help improve blood flow
fellow Democratic candidates quickly
sent well wishes the three top polling
Democratic candidates are in their 70s
and Sanders is the oldest at 78
president Trump is 73 back in April we
asked Sanders if age is a concern what
about your own health is there anything
as you get older that you worry about I
am I thank God I'm knocking on something
here but it should be wood no one ever
knows what happens to you to me anybody
tomorrow but I'm melting
feeling pretty good recovery from this
procedure depends on the patient's
overall health says CBS News medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook
prognosis depends on a number of factors
including was there damage to the heart
muscle itself is there an irregular
heartbeat how well is the heart pumping
but if everything is fine and he has no
other medical problems and he hasn't had
a heart attack then he should be able to
hit the campaign trail in the
not-too-distant future many unanswered
questions remain especially perhaps how
this helps or hurts the Senators chances
Sanders and his aides argued that if his
medicare-for-all plan is enacted the
stent procedure he underwent
would be much more affordable in
sickness and in health
Bernie Sanders always manages to be on
message gap we like that and we
certainly wish him well nothing nothing
is more important than good health
nothing in the world
edie thank you very much you're also
always on point